This orthographic projection isn't normally how we directly perceive the world,
but it's a form we commonly use nonetheless. For example, assembly instructions
usually show an orthographic view. Architectural plans showing a front, side or
top view of a building use this sort of projection. You can take measurements
off of these types of views. Having the distortion caused by perspective
projection would most likely hinder our understanding of what we're seeing. An
orthographic camera can be used to examine objects from angles other than
directly along an axis, such as these views. A demo using an orthographic
camera follows. I find that I'm so used to seeing with a perspective view that
I perceive an optical illusion here. If I zoom out using the slider and look at
the whole scene, my visual system tells me that the front edge of the grid is
definitely shorter than the back edge. Try it yourself, and let me know in the
forums what you think.